dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with carries a knife here this is
a quick update on our plans with two
minute papers
the more I look at our incredibly
high-quality comment sections on youtube
or the community efforts that started
out on our subreddit the more I get the
feeling that we should strive to create
the community platform around the series
a platform for people who wish to learn
exchange ideas collaborate and help each
other for instance the two minute papers
data project has recently started the
initial idea is that there would be a
public crowd source database with
episode related metadata that anyone can
add information to this will be useful
for several reasons we can for instance
include implementation links for each of
the papers for the ones that have source
code either from the authors or some
independent implementations from the
community we can also include keywords
on the topic of the episode such as
machine-learning recurrent neural
networks class simulations for an easy
way to search for a topic of interest if
we are interested in any of these we can
just easily search for a keyword and
immediately know what episode it was
referenced them the very same could be
done with some of the technical words
used in the series such as metropolis
sampling back propagation and
overfilling this way we could maybe
build an intuitive technical dictionary
with definitions and links pointing to
the appropriate episodes where they were
explained i think that would be the
ultimate learning resource and having
such a dictionary would be super useful
i was playing with the thought of having
this for quite a while now so this data
project has just started out on the two
minute papers subreddit but it can only
happen with the help of the community
and this means you if you are interested
in helping please drop by and leave us a
note I've put a link in the description
box looking forward to seeing you there
it seems that there is interest in doing
such collaborations and experiments
together between you fellow scholars
imagine how cool it would be to see
students and researchers forming an open
and helpful community brainstorming
running the implementations and sharing
their ideas and findings with each other
who knows maybe one day
a science paper will be written as a
result of such endeavors
please let us know in the comments
section what you think about these
things would you participate in such an
endeavor as always will love reading
your awesome feedback also in the
meantime huge thank you for the
following fellow scholars who translated
our episodes to several languages if you
wish to contribute to click the COG
wheel button in any video on the lower
right click subtitles / cece then add
subtitle / cece I am trying my very best
to credit every contributor if I have
forgotten anyone that's not intended
please let me know and I'll fix it
meanwhile on patreon we are currently
oscillating around our current milestone
reaching this one means that all of our
software and hardware costs are covered
which is quite amazing because creating
YouTube videos with high information
density and short duration is the very
definition of financial suicide it's
very helpful for us to have such a
safety net with patreon also there was
an episode not so long ago about the no
two minute papers machine which was
bought solely from your support and i'm
still stand by this I try to explain
this to close members of the family that
we were able to buy this new machine
with the support of complete strangers
from the internet who have never met
they said that this is clearly
impossible apparently it's not
impossible and so many kind people are
watching the series really thank you so
much when we reach the master after debt
we will be able to spend one percent of
these funds to directly help other
research projects and conferences please
remember that your support makes two
minute papers possible and you can
cancel these pledges at any time
also if you don't feel like using
patreon or don't have any disposable
income that is completely fine i'd like
to emphasize that none of this is
required
it's just an option to help and we
completely understand that it's not easy
to make ends meet for many of you even
with lots of overtime at a tiring and
difficult job two minute papers is
always going to be here and will always
be free for everyone
we would like to spread the word so even
more of us can marvel at the wonders of
research
just watching the series and sharing
these episodes is also a great deal of
help and we are super grateful for it
it is really incredible to see how the
series has grown and how many of your
fellow scholars are interested in
research and the inventions of the
future let's continue our journey of
science together in the meantime google
deepmind and Blizzard has a mouse a
joint effort to make it possible for
computer programs to play starcraft 2 a
famous real-time strategy game from the
start of 2017 whoa there was a question
about the first thing I will do when
this project takes off
well of course I take one week of
vacation and write an AI that can play
against itself and watch with tremendous
enjoyment as they beat the living hell
out of each other and other real players
if I heard it correctly in one of the
upcoming championships computer
algorithms will also be allowed to play
and who knows maybe defeat the reigning
player champions you know like in chess
and go we are living amazing times
indeed i'm counting the days
super excited thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time